so how would you choose a topic for your
project this is going to start with
those of you
that are just planning to right you are
just thinking about
developing a project idea and maybe
you're thinking
how do i do something like a publication
that i read
or maybe you're thinking how do i do
something in
an area where i'm naturally interested
in but i really don't have the data
to start doing that kind of an
experiment
so that's the first point that i think
we should start
from is the topic that you already know
and care about so if you're currently
doing
uh your phd you've selected a topic
you're maybe thinking of a particular
experiment
and you want to understand how to make
it more
impactful how does omics data factor
into this
if you're already conducting experiments
and you've collected data
you might be thinking how do i find
additional data
that i don't have the capability to
generate myself
but i really want to use it to make my
project more
impactful or i want to develop a new
hypothesis
but i don't have the means to generate
the data
so that would be the first step is
really having
a topic that you know or you care about
and to ask yourself is that a topic that
i know and care about
is can you prepare a few slides to
explain
the topic background and can you see
yourself spending a few months
researching the topic so really
for those of you that are planning some
kind of bioinformatics analysis
even though it's just data analysis it
still takes time
so you have to be prepared to dedicate
at least several months
just to the analysis the second part
is what will be interesting to your
audience so i'm assuming
that the majority of you here are
already in
some kind of research and so if you
think about
your audience what is that audience that
audience could be
your peers your mentors other faculty
they could be the broader research
community and
this is not a trivial question for any
of those
audiences within a niche there's already
a niche
within every domain there are specific
topics that are
more interesting they're more
on top of everybody's mind and so
that's the second component here the
third
component is that you have to have the
data
and you have to have um some kind of a
body of research that is available about
that topic right so if you are planning
to conduct this research
and there's no data you're back at the
same place right so it's got to be
something
that comes from availability of data
now in between at the intersection of
these three
is the project that you want to focus on
and i want to talk about this a little
bit more
in detail because that's where typically
most of the participants that we have in
our programs
fail they fail to quickly identify
a relevant topic that is interesting to
a broad community
and find data that can help them
make some kind of an interesting project
out of that question
so i think that defining that question
making it specific
and making it actually possible to
execute
is a big challenge that needs to be
overcome
now when people publish they typically
publish from primary data that they have
collected
and that is the raw data the first
hand observation that they have
themselves collected
in many cases you are not going to be
the person that generates that primary
data because
so much data is already available but
that doesn't mean
that you cannot start your project from
there
and so what we will do in the context of
the first part of our program
is we're going to kind of explore all of
these
sources of data to generate a hypothesis
or develop a problem or a question
and then find the solution or the answer
and i think that that has to do with an
overview
of literature but also the available
data sets
and it has to do with a good founding
a good established understanding of
methodology how
have others extracted insights from data
sets that they described
and so the typical process that we
recommend
is to start from where you are and try
to
define what is the specific
data set what is the problem statement
that you have
and then trying to work through on how
to make that
into a much more specific question
because that really
can help you then narrow down the number
of options that you have to do
your analysis and it will
streamline or simplify the
interpretation
at the end and so the first part is to
review
available sources and to categorize
them by some kind of type for example
you can think of
different types of research articles
that present
the current topics or that focus on one
specific thing
you can focus on a number of different
categories but you have to build out
that overview or that kind of a
landscape
of where you are compared to what's
already out there
and then it will be more clear where are
the specific gaps
unanswered questions maybe controversy
right so some people don't agree with
each other and maybe a debate
and those are typically the most
interesting things
to address so that gap those unanswered
questions and those debates around
different topics is the place to focus
to define your question or hypothesis so
here what we want to do is we want to
kind of review what's out there make it
more specific
where do we want to focus and that
typically
will be in the place of gaps and
unanswered questions
now a good place to start is from
existing projects right so a part of
review
and by the way this doesn't have to be
just in your domain
is to see how have other people
try to answer questions with data
and so what we've done is over the past
several years we've gone through
publications that focus on specific
types of problems and specific types of
data
and have extracted insights from that
data by processing
exploring and analyzing those data sets
so we've collected
a number of projects that you can
start with as a springboard into the
process
because they clearly take out the
methods
break down those methods into tutorials
that you can follow
explain the data set and how the data
set was collected
and why that data set is an impactful
way to study that particular topic
and once you've gone through a few
examples it becomes
almost easy for you to start thinking
about the data
in terms of a hypothesis that could be
answered
with a given set of tools and so when it
comes to your project you are really
going to be able to take those examples
and leverage the same types of methods
to apply to a data set of your own
so this is how the program that we
envision
is going to work we're going to first
follow through
and learn about some of the basic data
types and how they are processed and
analyzed
then we will introduce case studies and
those case studies will provide you with
a good
overview of the topics where the data
came from
how it was analyzed and what are the
results
at the end you should develop a
framework
of how to apply such thinking to any new
data set or a problem
that you identify